Hey friends and welcome to the Riker Medical Podcast.
Riker Medical is a platform for education focused on emergency, transport, and critical
care medicine.
We believe that the sharing of knowledge should be free, accessible to all, and that innovative
use of technology can facilitate that effort.
This podcast is just one piece of that whole project.
Also, while we may mention medical treatments and interventions along the way, remember
that we are just strangers on the internet and don't do things you aren't allowed to
do.
For more information about the project, visit us at RikerMedical.com.
Cool.
I guess we can just dive right into this then.
Dan, Taylor, thanks for coming on today.
Thanks for having me.
It's exciting to be able to chat and catch up.
Yeah, for sure.
It's been a little while.
I guess it hasn't been that long because we saw each other just, I guess it has been.
When was it?
Like maybe May?
Maybe?
I don't know, man.
Time is weird.
Yeah, it feels like it's been a long time.
Yeah, I appreciate you coming on.
For those of you who don't know Dan, Dan is a paramedic, and we'll get into a little more
of his background shortly, but he's had a pretty cool career in that he's done a lot
of work as a medic in, I guess you could say, like atypical environments.
That's kind of what we're going to talk about a little bit today.
We just start off with Dan, do you want to talk about how you got into EMS and working
as a medic and then we can get out from the normal 911 operation stuff?
Yeah, I mean, kind of going way back, I did some volunteer stuff in high school with like
wilderness search and rescue, thought that was kind of interesting.
Went to undergrad, got involved with an ambulance corps, became an EMT, figured out that
kind of working on the ambulance was a lot of fun and started thinking about it as a
career, became a medic in New York, worked full time on the ambulance for a number of
years doing 911 and inter-facility in both urban, suburban and rural areas, which was
pretty cool.
I mean, I got a variety of patients, different transport times, and then through that, some
of the agencies I worked for would do like special event medicine for like triathlons,
big concerts, stuff like that.
So that was kind of my first exposure to like working as a pre-hospital provider away from
the ambulance in like a really formal way.
And that kind of opened my eyes in a lot and especially working alongside some really pre-hospital
forward physicians in those like special event environments.
So that kind of got me interested and looking for other things we could do.
I became a professional ski patroller and that was a lot of fun.
I got to ski and then I also got to start doing like medicine and like wilderness medicine
and working out of a backpack and really thinking about how the environment creates additional
challenges and how we're like resource limited and really trying to maintain a good quality
of patient care in what was at times a challenging environment.
And then that got me kind of into the wilderness medicine world.
And then so I started following like wilderness medical society and attending conferences
and additional classes kind of within that bubble as I was able and then started looking
for other things that I could do to expand my experience to encounter new problems.
That brought me to the film world, the TV and film world and I was able to work as a
set medic first in a couple of kind of wilderness environments.
I volunteered with Team Rubicon and I deployed to Greece and I worked in a refugee camp there
and that was my first exposure to like true humanitarian medicine and the problems, the
challenges, the complexity of dealing with not only those populations but then a foreign
healthcare system, seeing new medications, trying to work with local healthcare providers,
being a patient advocate through an interpreter, like all of these things that were connected
in some ways to stuff that I've done before but didn't necessarily in some cases have
formal training in.
And then basically from Greece I kind of kept saying yes to things.
I was able to start doing some teaching in like the wilderness and an austere medicine
world.
That got me more contacts and more experience and I was able to learn more through that.
Eventually worked offshore in the oil and gas and commercial fishing industry as a medic
in the Gulf of Mexico and Alaska.
Worked with small NGO and deployed with them a few times in Iraq, Sierra Leone, Mexico,
Ukraine.
And yeah, kind of kept attending training, looking for new opportunities and then growing
my network and through that I was able to learn different skills, step into different
roles and just kind of try to have fun and make the world just a little bit better along
the way.
Yeah, that's awesome.
Yeah, I want to try and remember to like come back to that idea of as you do more of this
type of stuff, just that network you create and you build for yourself really opens up
a lot of possibilities because I know that was something that I struggled with early
on in like wanting to do like overseas work that you just don't know where to go and then
eventually you wake up one day and like you're in boxes full of opportunities.
You're like, oh, shit, now I have to like now I have to decide like how to prioritize
where I want to go.
Yeah.
But yeah, that's awesome.
That network also makes it easier when you start getting those opportunities and you're
trying to like vet people or organizations or like you're being asked to go to a country
you've never been to.
But if you can just text somebody and be like, hey, Krista, you've worked here for a year.
What can you tell me about X country?
And that makes the deployment process and even the work on the ground is like so much
smoother and safer and more comfortable in a lot of ways.
Yeah, for sure.
And then what do you well before we talk about what you're doing right now, what were you
doing up until just a few weeks ago?
Yeah, so basically the last year.
So I have a pretty strong history working in Ukraine.
I spent most of 2019 there, most of 2022 after the full scale invasion, some of 23.
And then from April of 2024 until yeah, just a few weeks ago, I was I was working in Ukraine.
So most kind of the last like two, three roles I had were all clinical.
The last one I was working for a defense contractor, a US company.
I was their medic and they have some foreign personnel in country doing kind of like an
advise, assist and accompany a sort of mission.
So I was their their medic.
And then immediately before that, I was working very close to the front lines doing patient
care, a mix of role two, which is more like level two trauma center, like similar equivalency.
And then working in Medivac, which technically like it's a medical evacuation.
Maybe we can talk about a little bit more, but it was a little bit closer to critical
care transport, because we're taking patients that are pretty sick, they've just come out
of the operating theater, and now we need to move them to a higher level of care.
And that was, that was one of the places where I really started thinking about this conversation.
And then I also spent time working at a stabilization point, which is, it's a fixed facility, but
it's very small, it can accommodate one critical patient at a time, and then a couple of like
greens and yellows.
They're typically staffed, the ones I was the one I was in and similar size are typically
staffed by four people.
You'll have a physician or a provider, I filled in that role as an advanced practice
paramedic, combat medic, and then usually two Ukrainian soldiers who have like some degree
of basic trauma TCCC training, but they're not considered healthcare providers.
And so that facility was underground, it was fairly close to the front, because we had
to be because we were the first people to receive some of these casualties.
So we needed to be able to make, to be close enough to make a difference in some of those
cases.
And we would do temporary stabilization and then very quickly evacuate them to the next
level of care, which would be kind of the more of a proper role one, which is like a
maybe level three trauma center.
And then a role two is more like a level two trauma center.
Right on.
And I think I remember not too long ago, Quorum had a podcast out talking with someone who's
done a lot of work over in Ukraine, and they kind of talked through like disambiguating
all of these terms, because there's like, yeah, it varies a little bit on the context.
But if anyone is interested in that, I'll see if I can track that down and put a link
in.
And the role terminology is US military and NATO.
So and I've never served in the military, I've worked for the US military, and I've
done training for other militaries.
So I've, you know, I've learned a lot of this stuff as I've gone.
But yeah, so just for the terminology, that's and co-rom is a great resource for not only
the podcast, but for training in general.
Yeah.
And you've also you've been on the Quorum podcast before, if I remember, right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Yeah, I think two years ago, I talked about kind of like the first I talked about most
of the stuff I did in in Ukraine in 2022, and a bit more detail.
Right on.
Awesome.
And then what about now, because you recently had a big transition, I guess you could say.
So where are you at these days?
Yeah.
So now I'm in North Carolina.
I just moved back to the US and took a full time job.
I work for a private organization that does disaster response with a focus on the Caribbean,
Central America and the South Pacific.
And I'm part of our forward response team.
So we we respond very quickly when we're invited.
So my role now is a mix of medicine, rescue, logistics, communications, a little security,
some water sanitation, hygiene.
But I'm kind of a disaster generalist with a focus on natural disasters.
Awesome.
Yeah.
And like that breadth of experience is kind of why I thought it'd be good for us to chat.
So a little bit of a disclaimer here is that this is actually Dan's idea.
Dan has done a lot of like, I guess you could say like public facing stuff.
He's like taught at conferences and like been on a number of podcasts, I think there's been
more than one, correct?
Yeah.
Yeah, there's been a couple.
I'm not very good at self promotion, but I've done a couple.
But he had asked me this last year to if I'd be interested in presenting with him at a
conference.
So we kind of like put this concept together, but it never quite panned out.
But I thought it might be a good idea to just chat about these things here.
So the initial concept was like discussing like how you can use paramedics and specifically
like paramedics who are trained in like the critical care transport side of things, like
how you can use them as an asset or a force multiplier in more austere settings, like
whether that's humanitarian response or like embedding with the military for like conflict
response or things like that.
So yeah, that's kind of why we decided to have a chat today since we missed the opportunity
on that conference.
Yeah.
I mean, you you're a great example as well, right?
From Haiti to Ukraine to Gaza to Mexico.
I mean, you've you have this incredibly high level of training and experience and you do
like very traditional critical care stuff.
Right.
And then you also go to these sometimes horrific places and employ those skills.
And that was yeah, that was part of what kind of made me think about it.
And it was also I was looking at some of the patients and some of the equipment that I
was encountering in the role to in the medevac and thinking, you know, it would be really
great if I had an adult like Ryan here to be able to help and reassure me.
And because like you've you've legitimately done a lot more critical care than I have,
like I've passed the exam.
Like I know some stuff I can look things up.
I know where resources are.
But that doesn't account or that doesn't fully address the lack of like direct experience
and real high quality mentors.
So I think like someone with your background is an incredible resource in these types of
environments.
Yeah.
And I think that's one thing that we'll probably like touch on later is that there's you're
never going to there's no one person who like has the breadth of experience to like
make or break a response like in this general scene.
So like team composition is like a huge component of it.
So if you have folks with like, you know, like different types of experience in this
like general like paramedic or paramedic center, critical care transport realm, and you can
bring them together, I think there's a lot of value there.
So you know, like someone in my exit, like for me, for example, like I have a lot of
experience in like, you know, like very acute critical care transport, but maybe less so
in like the operation side of like working in specific environments.
So yeah, it's like, I think that was why we decided it would be good idea to collaborate
on this a little bit.
Yeah, absolutely.
So just maybe to set the stage, what are some like, what are some examples?
I know you've mentioned some of the work that you've done, but just in general, like,
what might be like a good use case for using a critical care transport clinician or a paramedic,
I guess these CCT folks could be like nurses as well.
But someone who has that experience like doing the critical care transport side of things,
like what would be a like a use case for them in one of these contexts?
Yeah, so I think there's two kind of general cases that I think can be really powerful.
So if you have a gap between surgery and the kind of next highest level of care, if
there is no indigenous critical care transport, there's a real possibility that surgeons could
do amazing work.
And then the patient dies during that transport because the vent settings are wrong because
the patient is starting to come up from RSI, right?
Because there's unrecognized bleeding.
Like there's so many things that could go wrong that would negatively alter that patient's
outcome.
Because it's one thing like even in the US emergency medicine as a physician discipline
is relatively young.
That is even more so true in other countries.
So then the idea of having critical care transport ability that is not a physician or an
anesthetist is pretty rare in some places and doesn't even exist in some places.
I mean, there's some places where your regular 911 ambulance person is closer to what we
would consider like an EMT or an advanced EMT, right?
So then we take somebody right out of the OR, so whether it's operational or patient
volume, for whatever reason, they're not able to convalesce for an extended period, you
know, a couple feet from that operating theater.
They need to quickly move from there to somewhere else.
That critical care provider can do a really incredible job dealing with all of those conditions
and making sure that the patient does as well as possible moving from basically point A
to point B.
And then I think the caveat with that is that, you know, pre-hospital people tend to be pretty
flexible with equipment, protocols, medications.
I mean, even in the US, like, you know, I've dealt with shortages on benzos or, you know,
saline, right?
We're using we're used to having to make some adjustments.
And so now if you take that critical care person and you put them in this, maybe it's
a foreign ambulance, different meds, whatever, as long as you give that person a little bit
of time, especially with medications, if you give that person a little bit of time to read
up on the meds that they now have access to, to play with the ventilator, to play with
the pumps, right, to get familiar with that different equipment, they have the plasticity
to be able to say, yeah, you know, event is event, I'll look at the manual, I'll work
through the modes, like, I'll figure out what is proprietary and, you know, what I'm
what I know the concepts of.
And then they'll be able to do a great job with that patient.
Whereas I think other health care providers or physicians may be much more uncomfortable
doing that.
And maybe they still do it.
I don't know, like, I don't have any evidence to support if there would actually be a difference
in outcome.
But I think everybody is going to be a little bit more comfortable if somebody who is already
more comfortable working in that environment is able to do it.
So that's kind of like the one the first kind of general case.
And then the second one is if we're dealing with things like significant pain management,
procedural sedation, in a somewhat low or lower resource environment, where, you know,
if we're going to RSI someone or if we're going to do procedural sedation, the quality
of care needs to be the same, whether we're talking about an operating theater in sub-Saharan
Africa or Ukraine or the US, right?
We might have to make changes.
Maybe we use a medication that has a slightly worse side effect profile, right?
That might be the only thing we have access to.
But we're still not going to let that patient desat, right?
We're still going to pre-oxy it.
We're going to do all these things that we are trained to do to ensure that those patients
have the best chance possible.
And so if we already know how to do RSI sedation, if we're already comfortable giving fentanyl
or, you know, whatever meds we're talking about, we can take that from a moving vehicle
and now move that to a patient care room in a facility where maybe the alternative, if
we're not there pushing those meds, is that the patient goes through an incredibly painful
procedure without pain meds or with Tylenol, you know, oral or IV Tylenol as the only thing
for like wound abridement.
And I've seen this firsthand.
But if we have that person that is comfortable with these meds, that is comfortable monitoring
that patient and is comfortable kind of like setting themselves up in a new space, now
you can safely do procedural sedation or RSI or whatever it might be in that environment.
And we have made things a little bit better.
So yeah, so I think that's kind of a way to transition those skills over to that other
environment.
And especially if we're talking about the in-hospital, we're taking responsibility for
a small part of the patient care, right?
I'm not telling anybody to become a surgeon unless you want to go to medical school and
do all that.
But if you have a provider doing a procedure, you can focus on the pain management, the
sedation, the airway, right?
You don't have to worry about the leg that's being amputated or is, you know, they're
dealing with the X fix or wound change or whatever, addressing change.
You can just focus on the pain and the airway.
We're cool with that because that's something that we do every day, multiple times a day
sometimes, right?
Yeah, so there you go.
So those are two kind of general cases that I think make a lot of sense for us.
Totally.
Yeah.
And that first one you mentioned about just like doing the critical care role or the critical
care transport role specifically.
That was something like we realized very quickly in Ukraine, there was like a pretty robust
like 911 EMS system like even before the war.
But once there was like this influx of casualties that needed to get from point A to point B,
there was kind of a gap there.
Fortunately now, you know, the war has afforded like the medical system of Ukraine, like the
opportunity to like fill that gap.
So like now they don't, there are some niche cases, but for the most part, like Ukrainian
providers can now do that thing that we were doing initially early on.
It's more an issue of just being like generally under resourced.
Yeah.
I mean, I was so like I was in the Prokofsk area and we were still, I mean, as of like
February through May, basically of 2025, like there was still, there were some NGOs that
are providing it.
There were some Ukrainian medics that had been trained up to a higher level.
But it still, there was this challenge of like some of the military units had great
combat medics that maybe they could do like, you know, push dose fentanyl, push dose ketamine,
but they're stationed at a role one and a patient has just come out of the OR from a
damage control surgery.
They're on a vent, they're on a propofol drip.
They were also using mannitol in some cases, and they have Atrocurium on board as that
was their common, most common paralytic that I saw.
That's not part of T triple C, right?
That's not part of, you know, normal combat medicine.
Like if you look at the joint trauma system, there is the in route care guidelines, but
that's not T triple C. That's what, that's not what most military medics are learning.
So we still had this gap.
And now there were a lot of patients.
I mean, some of you are simple ortho patients, people that had rapidly stopped hemorrhage
and then got a transfusion.
Like those folks absolutely were well within the wheelhouse for the combat medics.
And they did a great job taking those and making the patients comfortable and doing
everything they could.
But yeah, it was the sicker kind of like post surgical cases that I saw the gap still.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
And I wonder, I guess I'm not totally sure like how much of that is like, that there
aren't folks with the training bursaries, if not enough of them, because there are some
like ambulance services now that are doing like critical care transport with physicians
who have worked pre-hospitally.
I just don't think there's a lot of them.
So there still is definitely an opportunity for folks with that skill set in Ukraine,
even today.
And it's people also, I mean, people that haven't been to Ukraine also underestimate
like it's how big of a country it is.
So if you need to cover that entire front of the war, and space out some critical care
capabilities between ambulances and we have these buses that do transports, that's just
like a logistics problem.
Yeah.
Right.
And you can't fly.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Flying is bad.
Flying is a quick way to have a hard landing.
Yeah.
And, and to Ukrainians credit, like there, there had been a couple of a handful of very
dramatic and daring like helicopter rescue missions where they did, and there's some
that came out of Mary Oopel early in the war, where they evacuated via helicopter.
But yeah, it's not, it's not a viable option.
And then especially with the increasing number of drones, like the long range stuff where
in one night you have 500 or 800 large like car size drones over the country, you can't
even say, Oh, well, we'll just drive them to Kiev and then, you know, put them on a
fixed wing and then take them out.
Right.
It's just unfortunately not really an option right now.
Yeah, for sure.
And then you mentioned the case already of like a critical care transport person helping
with like an RSI or procedural sedation.
Yeah.
What are some other like clinical situations like not necessarily taking over an entire
case, like taking over like the care of the patient from start to finish?
What is another like ways that these folks who maybe insert themselves to be clinically
useful?
Yeah.
And so kind of like a lower stress one, and we both did this in Mexico.
If you're dealing with sort of a more primary care type environment, you know, what like
the military would call sick call or like urgent care type cases in a refugee health,
like that sort of setting the hospital providers and we're great history takers.
We're good at vital signs.
We're good at recognizing sick versus not sick.
Right.
If we're looking at a line of 30 patients that are waiting to be seen, I would take
that pre-hospital provider and if they get a bad feeling about somebody, we're going
to pull that patient out of line and then try to figure out what gave the person that
bad feeling.
Right.
I mean, sometimes that's how we're catching the patients that are borderline septic or
you know, they severe mental illness or electrolyte issue, you know, septicemia.
Some of these things that can kind of be a slower onset, but that we've encountered
in our various settings before.
And in some of these populations, you have folks that they're tough, like they've had
hard lives.
They are tough and they are stubborn and they're not going to step out of line because that
would be rude, even if they are having crushing chest pain that radiates down their arm and
right.
Some of these things are like, well, I'll be seen when I'm seen, but that pre-hospital
provider can do that.
So in that context, we can do triage much like a hospital.
We can do the history taking the vitals.
We may be really useful, especially if there's a language barrier as kind of the first layer
of sorting.
So if you pair the paramedic, whoever it is with an interpreter, and so we're collecting
this information, we're kind of creating some order within the chaos that can often
work in these places.
The physical exam sometimes can be time consuming.
And so if we have somebody maybe with multiple soft tissue problems from some places you
have issues with bugs, with hygiene, this kind of stuff, you can have a pre-hospital
provider that does a really good physical exam in, you know, appropriate setting for
privacy and then they can start flagging things and say, hey, you know, this patient
has what looks like a pretty decent sized abscess.
You know, we're going to make note of that, but otherwise their vitals are great.
They don't have a temp.
You know, we think it might be kind of an isolated thing or, you know, we're seeing,
you know, this is severe phlebitis and I am actually seeing a fever on this patient.
So again, we've combined doing a good, really basic physical with that history taking and
the vitals and now we are maybe making a difference in that patient's outcome because in a lot
of these settings, the physician level provider, there's often not enough of them.
And so if we can do a really good job and act not only as a physician extender, but
really to help prioritize and truly triage these folks, that can make things a little
bit easier.
We're also, we're used to stocking our own bags, right?
And restocking.
So if you take a pre-hospital provider and you say, hey, we've got a, you've got multiple
boxes of donated medications and we have a hemp, a cabin, whatever, that's going to be
our pharmacy, like we've gone through boxes and restocked things and, you know, we know
that you're supposed to organize things in certain ways.
So it's maybe not something we were formally trained to do in a classroom, but we've all
restocked ambulances, you know, all this stuff.
And so it's this kind of other thing that yeah, we can do.
I mean, anybody that's also worked for maybe a more budget ambulance service has probably
had to repair equipment before, you know, so, you know, maybe you're good at troubleshooting,
you know, the life pack 12 or, you know, whatever, whatever stuff.
So maybe that's kind of another thing.
Yeah.
Now those are all good examples.
And in my experience, I don't know if yours is the same, but I feel like when I first
started doing this kind of stuff, the like filling gaps in like a provider's workflow,
like always seem kind of intimidating, like doing the history when I like didn't know
what to do about the diagnosis part or like doing the exam when I like wasn't sure about
the treatment part that that initially when I was like first getting to this kind of work
was like a challenge because it, yeah, it feels like very strange.
Like you're like, you know, getting in someone's way or like wasting time.
I think there's definitely a way to do it that facilitates a workflow rather than impeding
it.
Yeah.
But, and you already mentioned team dynamics and team composition, right?
And I think this is where having the right type of physician provider in the environment
where you guys can sync up beforehand and the pre-hospital, you know, the pre-hospital
provider, the EMT paramedic can say, Hey, these are, you know, these are the things
I'm comfortable with.
I'm thinking I might be able to fill in and help in this way.
And then the physician can say, yes, that's going to be helpful.
Or actually, I think it's going to be more helpful if you do XYZ.
I forgot to mention like a 12 lead, right?
We're not only talking, always talking trauma.
Sometimes we're talking medical patients.
So you know, if you have somebody like in some of these settings, we do have 12 leads.
They have become smaller, less expensive.
And you can get 12 leads that are standalone from a cardiac monitor, right?
So something like flagging a patient that has cardiac risk factors and maybe has ambiguous
symptoms, and then the paramedic throws them on the 12 lead and then brings them over to
the provider.
Like that saved everybody a little bit of time.
You know, so yeah, I think it's, it's about kind of knowing yourself, knowing your skills,
and then having a team where you guys can have this kind of open conversation.
And I've had physicians say like, Hey, I'm really uncomfortable doing whatever.
Because sometimes you get a physician that has a specialty, but it's been years since
they did, you know, family medicine, women's health, primary care, right?
And they say, Hey, look, I'm great at urology, but I haven't seen a Peds patient in 20 years.
All right, cool, man.
Like I work on a pediatric critical care transport, right?
I see kids all the time in some cases, right?
So you have people that can identify their strengths and weaknesses.
And yeah, it comes down to having that, that team and the dialogue.
For sure.
Yeah, it's a good point about the providers themselves being in a setting that they're
not used to, like in a disaster situation.
I mean, remember here during COVID, we had like family med docs, like working in like
makeshift ICUs, taking care of, you know, a whole suite of patients on transport ventilators
basically.
So yeah, I think that's a good point.
Like where I'm working now, we have a lot of like local physicians that we work with.
They are like the, you know, the primary, you know, the primary ones like providing
treatment in the emergency room.
But most of them aren't emergency medicine doctors.
Like before, before the war, there were pediatricians or family med docs or, you know, like always
worked outpatient.
So that's definitely worth keeping in mind.
And then when some of these places, we also just have like regular, especially if you're
in like a refugee camp type setting, sometimes people just have like regular run of the mill
emergencies hypoglycemia, you know, seizure disorders, things like that.
And that's exactly the patient that you want a paramedic to deal with because you're out
of hospital.
They're having a sudden onset medical emergency.
Cool.
Like we can do that all day.
So it's going to be a, usually outside of like a conflict, it's going to be a small
number of like true emergencies.
But when things go sideways like that, you want somebody who's comfortable dealing with
it.
So yeah.
What about situations in which like you might have to like do things different than you
normally would have like deviate from like preexisting clinical expectations.
Yeah.
So this is one of the places where there are some documents that can absolutely help us.
Um, I think I, like I said in the beginning, we, we, we're not trying to do cowboy medicine.
We're trying to really maintain an appropriate standard of care for our patients.
So things might look a little bit different, but the fundamentals should be the same.
So if we look at the joint trauma system, there are clinical practice guidelines for
prolonged field care for critical care transport.
These are publicly available documents and they will, they granted they are written for
the U S and kind of NATO audiences.
So sometimes they might talk about specific equipment that's not affordable or, or there's
an assumption that, you know, a helicopter is going to be there in 30 minutes and then
a C five is going to be there in an hour.
But there is a lot of good content in there because fundamentally they are considering
a more austere environment.
So from an equipment standpoint, like we, uh, you know, capnography is going to be an
incredible tool, uh, for, for a lot of our airway stuff.
So if we don't have a proper, you know, a life pack, uh, 15, we don't have a Zoll monitor
with the capnography built in.
Um, there's a device called an Emma.
That's this little thing.
It's a little bit bigger than a pulse ox.
It goes between your airway device and your BVM or your vent.
Uh, and it gives you, uh, depending on the generation, because there's three of them
now, um, it will give you definitely a, a, uh, entitled CO2 number and a respiratory
rate.
Uh, that's the first generation.
The second generation will give you a wave form plus those two.
And then the third generation gives you Bluetooth connectivity so you can, um, you know, wirelessly
connect to that device and monitor remotely.
Um, but so that's a nice little tool where we are still using capnography to confirm
an intubation.
Uh, it's just going to look a little bit different and we're going to use, like, I know some
people still carry color metric.
I don't want that.
I want real time continuous monitoring.
Um, I've purchased my own Emma.
Not a good deal on eBay.
It's something that travels with me.
Um, but I think if we are talking about doing professional critical care or critical care
adjacent patient care in these environments, we can bring a tool like an Emma.
Um, and we can use that, right?
Because we, yeah, I mean, everybody knows how important capnography is in this context.
Um, again, thinking about smaller devices, we might use a pulse, you know, a fingertip
pulse oximeter, um, much more than something connected to a larger monitor or event.
Um, and that might be our primary pulse ox.
Well, you know, with, with the understanding that you're, you, in some cases you may have
a little bit of a delay between central circulation and peripheral, but if you have a patient
in shock, you're going to have to deal with decreased perfusion in the fingers.
Um, so there are limitations, but now we can, with some smaller devices, we can still think
about appropriately measuring and monitoring our patients over time.
Um, we might look at using like low flow oxygen if our ventilator will accept that, because
maybe we only have like a portable, like a, like a home type oxygen concentrator.
So now we're running a low flow source, like up to six liters into our vent.
Um, so we're still providing, uh, oxygen.
We are just not providing it from a big tank because that's not available or maybe one
tank is available, but we're not going to be able to refill it very easily.
So we need to use that, um, pretty sparingly.
Um, some of the equipment, like some of the vents, some of the monitors might be a little
bit older than what we're used to at work.
Um, and so then it's kind of just a matter of pulling out the manual.
Um, I mentioned medications before we may have meds that we are, maybe we are familiar
with the class of medication.
Like it is a Benzo, it's a, um, uh, uh, uh, uh, depolarizing, um, uh, paralytic, but the
specific drug that we now have in our, our ampule, uh, is unfamiliar to us.
All right.
Let's spend a little time, you know, with PubMed or with another resource.
Um, if our local healthcare providers are familiar with that, um, we can figure out
kind of the pros and cons of using that.
Um, so we can look at our medications and try to figure out what adjustments we need
to make.
Maybe there are additional side effects.
And so we're thinking maybe this is something that produces more nausea or more hyper salivation.
Right.
And so we're going to pair it with another medication that we wouldn't normally have
to try to balance that.
Um, I mean, pain management is something that can be difficult.
And so maybe rather than just jumping first, um, to, you know, to, to a stronger dose of,
of fentanyl, because maybe we have a very limited supply of that.
Maybe we are going to try like PO, uh, ibuprofen and acetaminophen and see if we can take the
patients, you know, pain down a little bit with that, or maybe it's going to be IV, uh,
paracetaminol, um, you know, so maybe we're going to try other strategies to manage the
pain, whereas in a more normal environment, we could say, Oh, we'll just give enough fentanyl
and make them comfortable.
And then we'll be at the hospital in 20 minutes.
Right.
Um, so those are, I think some of the cases and again, going back to these clinical practice
guidelines, especially the prolonged field care and the prolonged casualty care guidelines
have these minimum better, best recommendations for whether it's airway management, pain management,
um, wound care and within these guidelines, there's different, um, procedures.
And so they'll say, you know, the minimum for a wound dressing is X, the better is Y,
and then the best is Z.
And so if you are packing or if you are at a local market or a store buying stuff, you
can say, Hey, we have a limited number of the best.
So we're going to save that for some specific patient populations.
And then, but we have a nearly infinite supply of the minimum.
Fantastic.
Let's, let's use that, um, you know, uh, in abundance and as appropriate, uh, but we don't
have to make that improvisation and that judgment call in the moment.
We can look at these guidelines and make good decisions in advance.
Understanding those guidelines are written by both physicians and people with significant
field experience and in some cases researchers as well.
Um, so that we are combining our understanding of the operational environment, the equipment
that we have available, and then these external resources to help us modify our care in really,
um, logical and, um, sustainable ways.
Yeah, that's awesome.
Um, so we talked to Farrah about a bit about, um, like how it might look in a clinical setting.
So I think that's fairly clear, but like, how does one, because somebody's interested
in this, somebody's listening to me like, this sounds awesome.
Like how do I do that?
Cause you and I both mentioned that like, it's not as easy as just like signing up and
going.
Like, how does the, how does the process work for like finding these opportunities and like
getting into this sort of thing?
Yeah.
So, so like one, so like some folks, if folks are already in the military, um, they may
have already gotten some of the medical training, especially on like the special operation side
that sets them up really well to work in these environments.
Um, for other folks, like we can, we can develop the knowledge and the skills incrementally.
So I mentioned part of my backstory was special event medicine.
So if you have access to that in your area, if you can work, you know, major sporting
events, NASCAR, um, you know, burning man, uh, you know, EDC, the big, um, uh, electronic
music festival, if you can work some of these big events, a lot of that patient care is
going to be treat and release onsite.
You're going to be working alongside, uh, physicians and NPs and PAs.
Um, and that may be kind of one avenue to start getting experience and potentially networking.
Um, uh, and it may also, depending on your, your, uh, employer, uh, they may be willing
to send you to some additional training.
Um, I think, I mean, if you have a part time job at an urgent care, like that's probably
pretty useful, especially if you have a team there that will let you learn more that will,
you know, show you other procedures, I mean, even just basic wound care, um, you know,
an, uh, incision and draining for an abscess placing a Foley, like these are things that
we don't normally do in, in an ambulance setting, um, that are super useful in either extended
care, you know, prolonged care or some of these, um, uh, like, uh, refugee health settings.
So if you're already working in that urgent care, if you work in an emergency department,
um, you know, tell, you know, if you have a provider that you're comfortable with, tell
them like, Hey, I really want to go volunteer on these types of missions.
Can I learn more in the ER?
Um, and of course, I mean, there's liability, like there's all these other considerations,
but, um, that may be a really good step forward.
Um, getting experience is always going to be useful, especially if it's experience with,
uh, a mentor, if you're able to join, um, one of the disaster medical assistance teams,
one of the, um, urban search and rescue, uh, usar teams, uh, those are all going to be
well-established programs.
There's a clear, uh, barrier for entry.
There are ongoing training.
There are experienced personnel.
It's part of a federal system.
Um, at least as long as those programs exist.
Uh, and so that may be a really good way to go from sort of being a street or a more
traditional transport provider to now working in a non-transport or a partial transport
environment with personnel that are, uh, that have experience doing the stuff.
Um, like the, the usar teams, um, I'm most familiar with them, not as a domestic resource,
but as an international film.
Um, I mean, there are several usar teams that used to deploy to places like Turkey after
they have a massive earthquake or Haiti.
Um, and the capability that those teams are able to bring is really, really remarkable,
not only on the medical side, but bringing in, you know, civil engineers and other types
of engineers and communications and all this other stuff.
Um, so DMAT and usar, I think would be really, really useful.
Um, look at the wilderness medical society.
Um, so they're a professional organization for wilderness medicine.
They have some, uh, clinical practice guidelines that are useful.
They also do conferences.
They do online, uh, uh, online classes and lectures.
Um, so that's kind of another organization that has multiple purposes.
Um, social media can certainly be useful.
There's a lot of NGOs and other organizations that will, um, you know, posts on Instagram
and you can, um, you know, look for the groups that are out there.
Um, you know, do your homework, do your due diligence.
Uh, you know, the, the organizations that are doing the most sustainable in some
cases, kind of less exciting stuff will probably be safer.
Um, the folks that are doing the really spicy and at times very interesting stuff,
um, will probably be more risky and you as an individual will have to take on more
responsibility for your wellbeing and safety and not only during the mission,
but also after the fact.
Um, so kind of think about, you know, small versus big organizations.
When you start looking at folks, um, but yeah, I mean, start small,
but look towards the wilderness medicine world.
Um, if you already have a big skill in mountain biking, skiing, climbing, um,
there are probably opportunities, whether it's through like national ski patrol,
um, or through, uh, other, other groups to use that skill in addition to your
medicine to support expeditions.
Um, I mean, so a lot of that's going to be volunteer.
Um, but that gets you thinking about, you know, I have an 80 liter backpack.
I need to be able to provide this level of patient care.
I also need to carry this amount of water, food, my own sleeping bed.
Right.
So now you are thinking about mission planning and logistics, and you're also
now thinking about, well, how do we get this patient out if we have a problem?
So now you're thinking about the different ways we can do that and the
manpower and, and, um, the evacuation resources, right?
Um, so yeah, but you, you would, to do a lot of the expedition stuff, you need
the underlying outdoor skills, whether it be, um, out nearing or mountain
biking, whatever, right?
To be able to function in that environment.
Um, and then you're going to add medicine onto that.
Um, so yeah, I mean, kind of follow your, your interests.
And if you already know somebody in your community, um, maybe it's, you know,
a paramedic who works part time, you know, at your ambulance service, or, uh,
maybe there's a physician in your area who's part of a wilderness medicine
fellowship, like reach out to them and see if they have a lead, um, uh, ultra
marathons are another place where it can be an easy step into getting some
experience because most ultra marathons will have some degree of medical support.
Maybe it's BLS, maybe it's more sophisticated.
Um, but you'll do a lot of foot care.
And honestly, that's pretty useful, uh, to learn how to do, because when people's
feet are in bad shape, like the rest of them follows pretty quickly.
Um, so yeah.
And then that also gets you thinking about, you know, limited resources
and evacuation and all that kind of stuff.
And then one of the things worth mentioning is there are many, many,
many, like NGOs or nonprofits that do like international missions.
So they're like, put a team together to go to whatever country or whatever part
of the country, um, to go do medical support just in general or for a specific
thing. Um, so that's kind of how, like, I kind of like edge my way into this space
was just going online and like picking a place I wanted to go and seeing like who
was working there and just sending blind emails and seeing what took, um, yeah.
Um, what about classes?
Like, are there any like specific forces you could take?
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
Um, so I mentioned the wilderness medical society already, they do, uh, two
conferences every year.
Um, those, you know, they'll have a variety of topics focused on care outside
of the hospital from, you know, uh, you know, from like mountain biking injuries
that are in our from a level one all the way to, you know, diving expeditions and
things like that, and they'll have pre-conference, you know, workshops that
are more hands on.
Um, so look at those, uh, and then like, there's a, there's a program called a
steer emergency care, uh, that I really quite like I've, uh, I'm not a instructor
for it. I've guest lectured on a couple of courses.
Um, that program.
So AEC is a, um, is a standard and then it is implemented by a number of different
organizations, but a steer emergency care is designed for professional responders,
people, uh, EMT or higher, um, who will be working in, uh, an austere environment,
uh, or remote environment.
So that's everything from, uh, people on a search and rescue team, um, ski
patrol, uh, offshore medics, uh, certainly like any folks doing like high
threat, um, you know, tight medicine.
Uh, and it's really looking at how do we plan for and treat casualties over a
longer period of, uh, and doing it in a really smart way.
And it's, it was created by the folks who created the prolonged field care
collective and wrote the literally wrote the book on prolonged field care, the PFC
CPGs, um, so austere emergency care.
You can just search for that.
Um, there's a organization that, um, I do teach for so like disclosure, um, anyone
not ready, um, they're based in Colorado and Colorado Springs.
Um, I think they're an awesome group.
Uh, they're cool people.
They, uh, a number of their folks have been over to Ukraine, um, multiple times
doing some really, uh, high value teaching.
Um, so check them out.
Um, they can also do some like, uh, custom courses if your organization
wants to like bring them in.
Uh, there's ragged edge solutions, uh, that also teaches AEC and then they will
do, um, some private courses as well.
Uh, so you can do a search for them, um, and see, see where they're at.
Uh, we mentioned earlier the college remote and offshore medicine.
Um, I'm definitely a big fan of their stuff.
Um, I know they have some online courses and then some in person, uh, ones as well.
And they also deliver the AEC program.
Um, they're quite good.
They have, uh, they're probably one of the most international organizations, uh,
training providers that I know of that they have instructors from South
Africa, Australia, um, Poland, Ireland, uh, the U S.
Um, so they ended up, so co-rom ends up bringing together a lot of different
perspectives, um, and then they, they do some courses in the EU, um, and then
elsewhere in the world as well.
Uh, so check them out.
Um, so I don't have a firsthand experience with the next two, but I know
they have a really good reputation.
Uh, so there's, um, SOA rescue SOAR.
Um, so, uh, in particular, they have an extended austere provider course and
then, uh, technical austere medical evacuation or TAME, um, those two
courses, I think they're both a week long.
Um, and they have both have a little bit different focus.
Um, but SOAR has a really good reputation.
I've, I've met most of their folks at a few conferences.
Um, and both of those courses, uh, help set you up to provide patient
care in a more austere environment with, with the understanding that you
are carrying drugs, you're carrying vents, you're, you're doing a higher
level of patient care.
Um, and then the final one I'll mention, um, European medics, uh, has just
started organizing some training.
Um, they have something called the tactical clinical operations course, um,
that seems, uh, and I have no financial affiliation and I haven't taken this
course, but it seems very similar to some of the trauma care that I've done.
Um, in terms of like working in these, you know, military, like role one, 0.5
type, like forward stabilization point, um, uh, areas.
And so I think that would be a really useful course because it's a higher level
of care than your average, like tactical medic course.
Um, but it's also not like advanced trauma life support, which is focused on
very much a, uh, well-resourced in hospital, uh, setting.
So I think, I think the TCO program from European medics is going to be good.
Um, and I know they, they're an organization that has really made an
effort to rapidly seek input, especially from, from people in Ukraine, um, but
from elsewhere, uh, to continually kind of evolve and push their content, um,
from social media to the stuff that they release on their Patreon, um, to, to
basically just evolve pretty fast.
Um, cause that can be, that can be a challenging process for organizations.
What about, um, like something non-medical?
What do you think about heat?
Yeah.
So absolutely.
So it's good to think about the non-medical training.
So, uh, heat or, um, hazardous environment, awareness training, um, there's
multiple different providers.
So heat is a pretty standard, um, and then there are multiple training
providers that will offer this.
Um, uh, some courses will be a little bit more focused on either one geographic
area or one threat profile.
And then other ones will be a little bit more of like a shotgun approach, depending
on who the primary clients are.
I think a heat course can be really useful.
It's going to cover, um, a pretty wide range of stuff from like, you know, using
a radio, which you're already familiar with, but then also like, if you're
approaching a checkpoint with armed, you know, non-uniformed personnel, how do
you deal with that?
Cause that's a real thing that we encounter not only in conflict environments,
but in some semi unstable non-conflict places as well.
Um, you know, how do you deal with, uh, attempted kidnapping or kidnapping?
What's your conduct after capture?
Um, you know, how do you deal with communications planning?
Like you're creating a pace plan.
Um, most heat courses will cover a little bit of first aid as well.
Usually like stop the bleed and a little bit more.
Um, but even if you already know, kind of gets and all that stuff, getting reps
in is always good and then doing it in a stressed environment, doing it with
team members who may have a much lower level of medical training.
Like I think there's really high value in that.
So yeah, I think a heat, um, or a heist course, both of those can be real useful.
Um, do your due diligence, uh, at the companies, you know, try to find reviews
on them, even if you are just searching on Reddit and you have a company in name,
you know, throw, throw the company name on Reddit and see if anybody's talking about it.
Um, uh, if you are a journalist, there are some organizations that do training, uh,
for journalists, they're going to be going into conflict environments.
So kind of look, look for that.
Um, and then, I mean, other non-medical stuff, like, uh, depending on where you
want to work, if you are able to take, um, you know, maybe it's swift water
awareness, um, maybe it's basic rope rescue.
Like there are some of these rescue things that even if you are not planning
to effect a technical rescue, maybe that is something to get yourself out of
trouble or to, you know, self rescue.
Um, especially if you are really drawn to the natural disasters and that sort of things.
Like, yeah, you might sort of be naked and afraid and kind of alone and need to rely
on non-medical skills to get yourself out.
Um, so yeah, I mean, time, time and resources depending, you know, take some
of those additional classes, especially.
No, I'm just on the rescue side.
If it's training that is designed for low resource environments.
So like, um, on the wildfire, Oh, and we didn't even talk about wildfire.
Uh, there are medical opportunities for employment in the world of wildland
firefighting, um, so people can get hired as, as a fire line, EMTs and paramedics.
There's also, um, REMS team remote extraction module support.
Is that right?
REMS.
Um, so there are these other, uh, other employment opportunities, but then there
are training opportunities, public enrollment training opportunities for
wildfire medicine for REMS teams that they're looking at.
How do you do a low angle rescue with, uh, with a, basically a small Fanny
packs worth of rope and hardware, right?
Um, that is probably going to be more applicable to some of these remote
and austere environments than the very traditional, like tech rescue, rope
rescue one and two where they say, okay, so we're going to pull the heavy
rescue truck up to the building.
And then we're going to take out a thousand pounds worth of carabiners and
you know, 10 mil, 12 mil rope and whatever.
Um, but the, if you're interested or if you're, especially if you're thinking
about like urban type stuff, you might look more towards, um, security
focused training, um, uh, you might even think about like, um, uh, hand tool
vehicle extrication as another thing.
Um, so yeah, I think, and you make a really good point of looking
towards non-medical stuff.
Um, because we could be the best paramedic slight, whatever in the world.
But now we are in a radically different environment that has new
challenges and new problems.
And so we need additional skills.
Um, uh, yeah, so, so really think about kind of rounding out, uh, the training
you have and if, uh, you know, language is always a cool thing, right?
So if, if you already speak a second language, fantastic.
Um, if you are good at languages and want to learn, um, pick up another
language because it, uh, it's never bad to be able to talk directly with your,
your patients or, or your coworkers or, or whatever.
And as Americans, we typically don't speak another language, which
is very uncommon in this world.
Um, and what about like all these horses seem super interesting, but what
do you do if you don't have any money?
Like you can learn languages for free.
So we'll leave that one aside.
But what about some ways you like self-directed learning?
Um, cause we all know that like folks working on a truck in a nine one
system aren't generally like rolling in cash, some ways you could like
develop a skillset to get into the space without like shelling out a
couple of thousand dollars for a course.
Yeah.
Um, so there are groups, so like Co-ROM and I believe the WMS, the
order of medical society will both do some like free presentations and
lectures. Um, so, you know, hop on those.
Uh, if you, if you do have any continuing education funds, even if it's
like two or 300 bucks a year, um, that might be enough to let you go to a
conference, but not a full, uh, like five day course.
Um, also the clinical practice guidelines that I mentioned, they are very well
written so you can go, um, go to deployedmedicine.com, set up your, you
know, your free account there, login, um, download the Prawn Casually
Care guidelines, and then start looking through, um, maybe start with
something like hemorrhage control that you are probably already fairly
familiar with and see what they do that's different and then, uh, or, um,
airway management or whatever, uh, and then start Googling, um, between
PubMed, um, between like Khan Academy, um, there's some, uh, Larry Melick is
a physician from Georgia who's got a channel on YouTube.
Um, there are some great resources where if you are looking at this clinical
practice guideline and they're talking about a med or procedure you're
unfamiliar with, you can use that as a springboard to then go find a credible
resource and say, okay, so they're talking about, uh, maybe it's, uh, doing
an incision and drainage for an abscess.
Okay.
So they talked about that in the clinical practice guideline.
I'm going to go look on YouTube on PubMed.
Um, family practice notebook is another really good resource.
Um, and you're going to start learning about that and you're going to see what
equipment is required for it.
What are the indications?
Uh, what are the comp, uh, contraindications?
What are the complications from this?
Now, at that point, you are not credentialed to do that procedure, right?
But you are starting to understand how these things fit together.
And now maybe you do have an opportunity because you work in an ED, uh, maybe
you're an ED tech, something like that.
You can say, doc, uh, can I observe the next IND you do?
Right.
And now you are taking some of that academic stuff that you've, you've kind
of gathered on your downtime and now you're starting to bring it into practice.
Um, so I think kind of a hybrid approach there with, with the clinical
practice guidelines being, uh, a good starting point, um, or the, the
wilderness medical societies, uh, CPGs as well.
Um, uh, that that's going to be another really useful, uh, useful tool.
Yeah.
I agree with like the minor procedures thing.
I think that is super useful to have like additional people that
can do that kind of stuff.
Like, yeah.
Yeah.
Like even like simple sutures, like pulling a Tony L.
I N D P like that kind of stuff.
Like you can pretty quickly like read up, wanted to understand what's going on.
And the next time you see one, like take a more active role in like first
observing and then like helping out do one.
But I think that kind of stuff is, is really helpful.
The other thing that I found really helpful, um, is like getting
more comfortable using ultrasound.
So that's something that is really useful in like most of these settings.
It's just being able to quickly do, um, you know, like on the trauma side,
knowing how to do a fast exam, um, saves a lot of time.
Cause in a lot of these places, it's just the physicians who can do that.
Um, but they also have to do, you know, they have to manage the whole patient.
So if you can offload that task with like a good degree of certainty that you
like know what you're looking for.
Um, I think that's super helpful.
And then once you know how to do that, it's pretty easy to scale up.
Like if you have access to a machine or, you know, you know, someone who
like bought one off of eBay, um, you can just, you know, like kind of extend
your exam so like, you know how to do a fast, like next time after that, if the
patient stable, like take a look at their heart and after that, like try and find
the IBC and just like kind of work up that skill set.
Um, I think that's something that, yeah.
And the price point is only going to come down on those.
Like right now, um, you can get a, like a butterfly first generation for like
around a thousand bucks, 1200 bucks, maybe.
Um, and yeah, they just get cheaper and cheaper.
So.
And all the towns, non-invasive.
So it's something that you can, you can practice on healthy patients.
Like the only consumable is the gel and your paper towels, basically.
Right.
So it's something that once you get started, it's, and especially if you are
alongside somebody who is more knowledgeable, uh, that's, that is a tool
and a skill that you can practice more.
Um, and then, I mean, with the ultrasound, like the, the diagnostics can be super
helpful, um, IV access, only crap.
Especially even just for a medical logistics standpoint, the cost of an IO
needle, like an easy IO or a Talon, we're talking like a hundred plus
dollars per IO needle, right.
Versus pennies for an IV catheter.
And if we have somebody who's deep in shock, yeah, it might be great to drill
them right away, but if it takes 10 or 15 seconds longer to find a deeper vein
with the butterfly or with another ultrasound, and then we throw in that
18, because we've now found a decent vein that was just a lot deeper.
Holy crap.
That is awesome.
Um, so yeah.
So like ultrasound guided IV, uh, and then I'm not, uh, I've had minimal
training and I, I'm not comfortable doing that on a patient, but regional blocks.
So being able to use ultrasound to, to effectively deliver pain management
for an entire leg, part of a leg, the foot, hand, um, that can reduce the
amount of your opioid burden.
It can reduce a lot of your side effects of the various pain meds we might have to
give, um, so for some, and I know paramedics that are fantastic with
regional blocks, um, there were more and more physicians in Ukraine, uh, that
were, were doing regional blocks on a regular basis.
Um, so yeah, like that's another awesome tool.
And then even in the pre-hospital, like the normal pre-hospital environment,
I wish we did that at all or more.
Um, you know, your, especially like your elderly patient who maybe already
kind of has a soft blood pressure and now we're pretty sure broke one or more things.
I don't know if I could stop their pain without like giving them fentanyl
or morphine, like that'd be cool.
So, um, yeah, so now a hundred percent ultrasound is a great tool.
And especially if you're, if you have a service, uh, that's already
deploying it in some way, it's really.
Pretty easy to learn more.
Um, and there's some great resources online.
Um, uh, yeah.
And, and the more patients you scan the better.
Um, even if you don't have a doctor next to you or a skilled, somebody who's
really skilled with all of these digital ultrasounds, you can save the image or
the video.
Uh, so if you're scanning somebody at the station and you're, you know, you're
looking for, you know, where Morison's pouch would be if they were bleeding
and you're not here, if you're seeing the liver, take that scam, you know, record
that video and then take it to somebody, you know, maybe it's, you know, grabbing
a doc at the hospital and saying, Hey, you know, we're doing training at the
station, can you identify what, what I'm looking at here?
Right.
Um, and that may be kind of a, uh, a way to help you get reps in.
Um, it also builds rapport with those providers.
They're like, Oh, the ambulance drivers are learning ultrasound.
Whoa.
Okay.
All right.
Maybe they're not ambulance drivers, right?
Like maybe they know stuff.
Um, so yeah.
So when, when we take an active role in our learning and we express, um, kind
of respect for that knowledge and, and trying to gain more, uh, that can really
help, help our relationships with our, with our coworkers and other settings.
For sure.
Okay.
And then I just have one more, one more question for you.
Um, what does your process look like for, let's say you've like done all this prep
work, you found an opportunity and now you're like getting ready to go.
What are some of my considerations when you're looking to go out on maybe,
maybe your first assignment or maybe just an assignment in general?
Yeah.
Um, I mean, if I know somebody on the project or somebody that's worked in
the area or worked on a similar type of, of mission, um, I'm probably going
to reach out to them, uh, and ask for some advice.
Um, I'll spend a few minutes Googling the country, the conflict, whatever, just
trying to get a slightly better understanding of the context of like,
what was the country like before this thing happened?
Um, you know, and then I'm also now starting to think about like, what
diseases are endemic to the area?
Do I need additional vaccines?
Um, the, um, the CDC's website used to, maybe it still does had travel
recommendations, um, for different places.
Like, do you need yellow fever?
Do you need, um, uh, you know, do you need prophylaxis from malaria?
Yeah, exactly.
Right.
So all that kind of stuff.
Um, uh, if I know that we're going to be dealing with a particular patient
population, um, I might like either do some like kind of reading in the
moment, or I might, you know, if, if I know I'm going to deal with burns, uh,
maybe I'm going to download a couple of like burn textbooks or clinical
practice guidelines with the intent that maybe those get used at the bedside or
maybe it's on the flight over the drive over.
I'm going to be reviewing some of that stuff.
Um, uh, and then just like basic stuff.
I mean, have copies of your passport copies of your driver's license, both,
you know, physical copies and digital, um, you know, consider having a second
smartphone, um, that's unlocked so you can put a local SIM in it.
So you have data and connectivity.
Um, if you can afford a Garmin in reach, um, even a first generation, that's
going to give you the ability to text message, uh, through the
already in satellite networks.
So it gives you a little bit of redundant communication.
Um, and then if you're thinking about SAT coms, make sure you're not going to a
country like India where SAT coms are illegal for civilians.
Um, so just kind of be, be aware of that.
Um, yeah.
Uh, I mean, like a basic trauma kit, you know, just for yourself, if you're going
to a conflict area, plus that trauma kit up a bit, um, if you can get an EpiPen
or, you know, something like that, even if you don't have an anaphylactic
reacting yourself, it's not a bad idea to carry, um, carry anther diarrheals,
uh, get a prescription for Zofran on Dacitron.
Um, because sometimes that happens and it's better when you have antiemetics.
Um, yeah, I mean, there's a lot of little stuff like you'll probably
overpack for your first couple of trips.
That's fine.
Like you'll learn it's going to be heavy.
Either you'll donate stuff, you'll, you know, whatever.
Um, yeah, I mean, it gets, I think it gets easier with time, um, with time and experience.
Um,
what about a med kit?
So I know, I think you and I are pretty similar in that we have like a lot of
our own like kits, but normally when you deploy, um, the assumption is that like,
whoever you're working for, like they have their medical stock.
Um, so you might be asked to like bring things for donation, but are there
things that you like to take along?
Yeah.
So I have, like, I have some basic stuff that, um, yeah, so I'll think about it in
two ways.
So if I'm just thinking about myself providing, uh, like doing patient assessments, um, like
independent of any patient care.
Um, I have a diagnostics kit that is, that I put together.
That's like the size of a, maybe a football.
Um, it's got a blood pressure, a manual blood pressure cuff with, uh, detachable
cuffs from, uh, either an infant or a small child up to a large adult.
Um, and then the, the cuffs just pop off the gauge.
It's got my stethoscope, um, an otoscope.
Uh, I have some fluorescein dye for, um, fluorescein dye test in the eye.
Uh, I have the light, uh, for that.
Um, I have a small glucometer with some test strips, um, a headlamp with some
extra batteries, uh, your analysis strips.
Um, I have, uh, a tiny, I have a little note pad to write in and then, um, uh, what's
a little, uh, like the NP's little spiral bound reference book.
You know, the one I'm talking about.
I think I think it's, is it Maxwell's don't know the name of it.
Yeah.
But so it's a little reference.
That's got, like, it's got, you know, cranial nerves.
It's got, uh, normal pregnancy stuff.
It's got basic lab values.
Uh, uh, it's got like a small two page, um, uh, basic physical exam
with like, you know, key findings.
So it's a small little reference.
I have a braslow tape that I keep in there.
And, um, because I don't like dealing with kids and they're scary when they're sick
and a braslow tape makes the math a little bit easier.
Um, so, uh, yeah, that's in the kit.
Uh, I feel like there's a couple of other, I have a pulse ox in there.
So like that, that kit is fairly compact.
That will like always go in my day pack.
Um, and then if I'm doing, uh, like Medivac more critical care stuff,
typical at a Fanny pack, that's going to be on my person.
Um, I'll have a really good pulse ox in there.
I'll have my Emma clear.
I throw a couple of pairs of nitrile gloves, my stethoscope, a pair of
trauma shears, and then when I was working in Ukraine, um, I had an additional, uh,
tourniquet, a little bit of gauze and, um, uh, some wound packing and, uh, and,
uh, elastic bandages as well.
Um, either for the patient or for myself, if something happened.
Um, and then, and that's in addition to like in my pockets, I'm always going to
have a multi-tool, a pen, a flashlight.
Uh, uh, usually I have the co-rom, um, field guide, either in a pocket or, uh,
in a backpack, I always have a notepad, a Sharpie, a pen, um, a headlamp on my
person in addition to the headlamp that's in my kit.
Um, what else?
Um,
Yeah, but so I'm looking at like the basic diagnostics to be able to collect a
set of vital signs, to be able to document those vitals.
Um, and then, uh, yeah.
And then, you know, the Emma, if we're really thinking about a sicker patient,
um, and then depending on like, because I've worked in the film world, uh, set
medics have to provide their own kit.
Uh, and then the production company pays the set medic a day rate and then they
rent the medical kit as well from the set medic.
So like I have additional stuff.
So if I know I'm deploying with a smaller, like lower resource NGO, like I
might bring like a small backpack that has like trauma supplies, if that's
going to be appropriate for my environment.
Um, you know, uh, yeah, I might just try to fill in an anticipated gap with some
of that personal stuff.
Um, and then I think redundancy is good.
Like I will usually have a trauma kit in my backpack, a trauma kit or parts of a
trauma kit on my person or in my Fanny pack.
Um, and then maybe something like, uh, in my luggage as well, um, that's, you know,
can be restock or can be additional.
Um, and that's, I, I don't know, I'm a slightly paranoid person.
So, uh, yeah, the redundancy is, is helpful when I'm worried about things.
Yeah.
I think that's probably something we could spend all day.
You and I talking about is like how we prep our kits for different, different
environments that, um, yeah, I was just curious.
Um, I think that's all the questions I had for you.
I was curious if you had anything else that you think would relevant to, to
mention to folks who are interested in this space, um, we're like, I think
they're interested now they want to get into it.
I mean, I think maintain a good sense of humor.
Um, this can be a really difficult space to work in for a variety of reasons.
Like the, you know, you go volunteer for somewhere for two weeks.
It's challenging in good ways.
And then you go home and you know, that was your two weeks of PTO for the year.
Right.
And now you're right back onto a 24.
I mean, there, there can be a lot of challenges.
If you make this into a career, sometimes it can be contract work and that creates
a whole nother levels of instability in your life.
Um, so just try to maintain a good sense of humor.
Be aware of your own, uh, like your burnout, your mental health, all that
kind of stuff, try to take care of yourself.
Um, in some of these cases you will, and maybe it sounds a bit shady, but you'll
see the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
best and worst of humanity.
Um, and that can change you.
And, and I mean, I worked nine one for multiple years.
Like I, I thought I had seen a lot of stuff.
Um, but the magnitude of some of the things that we deal with and, and frankly,
the hopelessness of some of the stuff that we deal with, um, in, in these deployed
settings can weigh really heavy.
Um, so kind of take care of yourself and also recognize that the, the more,
especially if you tend towards working in a conflict environment, the more you do
that, the greater the chances are either that you're going to be hurt or that
people you love are going to be killed or hurt.
Um, and that's unfortunately just a fact of life and it's something that you just
need to be cognizant of going into it.
Um, and you're not going to be able to save everyone.
You're not going to be able to save some of your friends.
Uh, you're not going to be able to save a lot of your patients.
Um, because the conditions that created the environment that we're stepping
into are so much bigger than any one person.
Um, but having said that we can make things a fraction of a percent better for
one person, maybe we teach somebody and that has a positive impact down the line.
Um, so I don't think it's hopeless or pointless.
Um, but I think we, we kind of need to have really open eyes, um, and be really
honest about the, the situations that we step into it because some of them are
truly, um, pretty massive and pretty, uh, pretty awful.
Um, also don't be surprised if your view of the world starts to change pretty
radically as you get exposed to other people, cultures, countries, um, problems.
Uh, who I am now is very different than who I was, uh, 10 years ago or
15 years ago, uh, for the, I think for the better.
Um, but, uh, yeah, uh, yeah.
So take care of yourself.
Yeah.
And I agree with all that.
I mean, it's a great place to wrap it up.
Cool.
Thanks for coming on.
Thanks for having me.
I appreciate it.
It was good to see you guys.
And that's pretty much it.
Thanks for tuning in.
Just before we hop off here, I just want to give a shout out to my friend, Josh
Pitman and his buddy, Kevin Pons.
They're the ones who put the music together for all of this.
Catch you next time.